pas
bonjour bienvenue sur des gonades mag
cette première émission pour représenter
cette émission nous avons la chance
d'avoir avec le grand maître
international puis je vois roland joffé
l'amabilité de venir c'est d'autant plus
appréciable qu'il est en train
actuellement de jouer un tournoi
international
pour cette première édition nous allons
parler de trois grands thèmes
d'actualité du monde des échecs dans un
premier temps d'abord une parleront du
tournoi zonal s'avère le tournoi de
qualification aux championnats du monde
qui a eu lieu en novembre par l'europe
des joueurs qui ont joué ce tournoi
ainsi que d'une partie intéressante du
seul français qui s'est qualifiée lors
de ce tournoi
ensuite nous parlerons de l'organisation
des prochains championnats du monde
détails auront un petit peu les dates et
ainsi que l'histoire de cette
organisation puisque c'est assez
intéressant de détailler cette aventure
est en fait nous parlerons de
l'actualité française avec donc le
tournoi de paris qui a lieu donc à
clichy exactement de maître
international que je joue au yoyo
harlange et du tournoi de belfort au
jeune prodige mondiale ponomariov qui
s'avère être un produit exceptionnel
peut être supérieure etienne bacrot nous
y reviendrons un troisième partie donc
bon soir
eloi bonsoir donc il doit tuer en train
de donner actuellement de jouer ce
tournoi international tu nous fais donc
le plaisir de venir pour cette émission
et tu va présenter avec nous ce magazine
diagonale max magazine sur l'actualité
internationale
oui comment se passe ce tournoi donc mon
tournoi se passe pas trop mal en fait
puisque bon pour l'instant je suis
troisième du tournoi
donc c'est pas une mauvaise prestation
vu que ce dossier un tournoi donc qu'on
appelle deux grands maîtres donc qui
regroupe plusieurs grands maîtres ainsi
que des candidats quand m donc pour
l'instant je suis en troisième position
il reste deux parties à jouer donc
j'espère que enfin tout va bien se
passer il reste à jouer des joueurs en
principe pas trop fort donc voilà pour
mon tournante
merci et doit donc maintenant nous
allons donc commencer cette émission par
d'abord nous allons parler donc du
tournoi zonal tournoi zonal zone 1 point
alors peut-être eloi tu vas nous
détailler ce que c'est que la zone 1
point du taux national d'avoir un
tournoi zonal c'est quoi c'est un
tournoi dont qualificatif pour les
championnats du monde c'est à dire que
chaque fédération propose ses meilleurs
joueurs pour ce tournoi et ses joueurs
se battent sur l'échiquier donc
évidemment pendant quinze jours pour
désigner les huit joueurs dans le cas de
ce tournoi zonal les huit joueurs
qualifiés pour les prochains
championnats du monde alors eloi
peut-être tu peux nous parler un petit
peu des fédérations
oui alors donc ça regroupe plusieurs
pays
donc par exemple donc il ya le
luxembourg la france la belgique les
espagnols qui sont très forts les et
anglais évidemment mais n'est qu'une des
équipes les meilleures du monde donc
système de sélection en france cette
année ça a été vraiment une sélection à
l'américaine c'est à dire qu'on a fait
le championnat de france
on a pris les six meilleurs et comme on
avait six places les six meilleurs
français sont allés là bas
enfin c'est pas forcément les meilleurs
styles c'est à dire c'est les meilleurs
joueurs du championnat de france
c'est à dire c'est assez ponctuelle
c'est sur un tournoi donc ces sélections
à l'américaine si si le meilleur jeu si
etienne bacrot avait terminé septième il
n'aurait pas été qualifiés alors qu'il
fait partie bien entendu des meilleurs
joueurs français
donc le tournoi donc à a eu un
déroulement un peu spécial c'est à dire
donc c'est en novembre dans la ville
d'andorre et le résultat a été très très
surprenant puisque nombreux favoris ne
se sont pas qualifiés et il ya eu
quelques surprises notamment donc
christian bauer qui est le seul seul
français à s'être qualifiée d' en
cendres oui c'est le cas peut-être on va
justement parler des joueurs qui
composaient ce zonal dont un petit peu
parlé de quel joueur joue et de quel
pays venaient un petit peu et surtout
des grandes vedettes qui composaient ce
tournoi et commentés résultats
de ce tournoi alors pour la france donc
on avait comme joueur on avait christian
bauer évidemment créer la surprise
nous allons revenir ensuite on avait
aussi donc le numéro un français actuel
qui jouait le bottier craquer loi tu le
connais bien je vais lautier c'est quand
même une grosse surprise qui se sont pas
qualifiés d'ailleurs oui peut-être
parler un peu mieux de son palmarès et
joël c'est vraiment c'était une grosse
pointure c'est vraiment le domine les
échecs français depuis déjà cinq ou six
ans donc là il a une certaine baisse de
forme en ce moment c'est assez
inexplicable ça fait six mois que ça
dure et joël donc n'arrive plus à
atteindre les mêmes résultats
qu'auparavant bon alors on peut rappeler
quand même à titre d'exemple que c'est
un des seuls joueurs au monde à avoir un
score positif contre kasparov
il a battu trois fois il a perdu une
fois donc c'est vraiment c'est tout à
fait exceptionnel puisque kasparov et
quand même le grand champion du monde de
tous les temps
donc voilà pour donc je vais lautier qui
est vraiment qui domine les et chaque
français depuis longtemps et là qui a
fait une contre performance de plus
c'est à dire il confirme en fait sa
méforme qui dure depuis à peu près six
mois
alors entre joueurs qualifiés qui était
donc proposé par la fédération français
qui ont joué ce zonage donc si tu es
qualifié préalablement pour sonnera pour
ce tournoi qualificatif aux championnats
du monde je le rappelle on a parlé à
christian bauer on a parlé
on y reviendra sur christian on a parlé
de joël gauthier on a aussi le jeune
prodige français qui a fait la une des
médias nationaux il ya de ça un an
puisqu'il a obtenu le titre de grand
maître international à l'âge de 15 ans
et quelques mois
14 14 ans la dent un quelques décades il
doit donc ce qui constitue une
performance exceptionnelle donc etienne
bacrot 10 étaient présents je crois
qu'il est actuellement numéro 2 français
en fait derrière joël gauthier alors là
aussi était une macro ne s'est pas
qualifié je ne sais pas peut-être eloi
tu vas nous parler un peu plus de 10 de
maquereau est ce ce résultat surprenant
alors en fait c'est pas si surprenant
que ça c'est à dire que etienne est
quand même encore très jeune il n'a pas
du tout l'expérience internationale de
joël lautier donc il est en fait il est
clairement il est clairement moins fort
est clairement moins expérimenté donc
dans ce tournoi il aurait pu créer la
surprise
il ne l'a pas fait mais le fait qu'il ne
soit pas qualifiée n'est pas vraiment
n'est pas vraiment un fait marquant dix
ans et il aurait pu faire un événement
et il se passe que il s'est pas qualifié
mais je pense que honnêtement qu'il
n'était pas encore assez mûr pour pour
faire une bonne prestation dans un
tournoi de ce niveau là ensuite deux
autres joueurs français au tournoi qu'il
y avait contre eux dira peut-être eloi
je crois donc qu'il y avait aussi eu
aussi dorfman et anatoly valserres ces
deux joueurs français un peu particulier
puisqu'il sont d'origine russe tous les
deux je crois ce sont donc de très fort
joueur et qui eux aussi ont n'ont pas
réussi à se qualifier et dorfman de
justesse oui à la radio cibl hoffman et
le champion de france en titre
c'est à dire c'est lui qui a gagné le
championnat trans cette année c'est un
c'est une légende en fait des échecs
mondiaux puisqu'il a été entraîneur de
kasparov au moment des matches kasparov
et karpov et kasparov était un peu
l'inversé dissidente
c'est un des seuls joueurs donc d'union
soviétique a osé se mettre dans l'équipe
de kasparov contre karpov qui avait
vraiment tout le pays derrière lui donc
y oscille dorfman a été entraîneur de
kasparov maintenant il a été entraîneur
détiennent bacrot entraîneur de veselin
topalov qui fait partie des cinq
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux actuellement
donc vraiment nocifs dorfman à une
expérience fantastique en tant
qu'entraîneur maintenant pour la
compétition il est un peu moins
un pointu un peu moins bagarreur en fait
il lui manque un peu le fighting spirit
ce qu'il faut pour faire vraiment un
grand champion
donc en fait c'est pas vraiment un
joueur c'est plutôt un analyste un
travailleur c'est c'est vraiment un
professeur d'échec alors donc sa
prestation ici a été excellente puisque
en fait il s'est qualifié par parmi des
huit premiers il a été premier 8e
ex-aequo c'était 8 ex-aequo dans ce
tournoi donc il fait partie des
malheureux en fait qu'ils n'ont pas été
aidés qui ont fait éliminer au match de
ce nom de départage donc iossif dorfman
on pourra revenir viendra plus tard en
fait a fait un très bon tournoi vu qu'il
est arrivé dans les premiers mais a
perdu dans les phases qui est
éliminatoire donc voilà anatoly weiser
c'est un peu différent
c'est à dire que l'anatolie weiser
maintenant se désintéresse un peu d
échec puisqu'il travaille dans le milieu
boursier comme de nombreux joueurs
d'échecs en fait c'est une reconversion
tout à fait plausible donc là il
ils ne jouent ils jouent moins aux
échecs donc sa prestation aux zones a
été un peu décevante puisqu'il a terminé
avec +11 ou 50% ce qui est donc un peu
en dessous de son niveau mais anatolie a
lui aussi manqué un peu d'énergie et
manque un peu de punch
disons que manquer même de deux
d'ambition en fait pour se qualifier et
il y avait un dernier français que
stéphane oubliez de mentionner c'est
gilles miralles donc qui lui et dernier
qualifié un peu qualifiés surprise et
donc son tournoi était totalement
catastrophique
un peu à l'image de son entraînement en
ce moment vu qu'une s'entraîne
pratiquement plus donc voilà pour les
donc les joueurs français qui jouait sur
ce tournoi évidemment va aussi parler
des autres des autres nations c'est très
important puisque on avait parmi les
grandes nations d'échec représenté en
avait évidemment l'espagne l'angleterre
et notamment la hollande je pensais que
trois pays les plus représentatifs on
ressemble peut-être l'allemagne
l'allemagne ne participait pas
l'allemagne ne participait pas c'est la
zone 1-2 c'est malade donc ce n'était
pas la même en double ou l'absence des
allemands sur 7 sur ce tournant là donc
pour les anglais donc on avait notamment
johnattan spillmann quand même une
légende des échecs puisqu'il a déjà été
demi-finaliste du championnat du monde
si je ne m'abuse pas c'était en 1989
bon mais tu as l'air bien informées donc
johnattan speedman en avait aussi comme
anglais peut-être
donc tony milestone imai ce qui est
également très très fort non johnson n'a
pas participé à ce tournoi très connu
alors il faut dire que ça reflète pas
trop le niveau le niveau des échecs en
angleterre disons la participation de
ces deux grands maîtres disons de second
plan
puisqu'en fait les meilleurs joueurs
anglais qui sont donc mathieu saddler
michael adams ou nigel short sont
qualifiés directement pour le
championnat du monde bien entendu donc
ici nous avons les enfin des grands
maîtres très très fort mais qui sont
quand même deux secondes de second plan
dix ans pour cette grande nation et
chicken et l'angleterre
et malgré cela évidemment ces deux
joueurs se sont qualifiés d'ailleurs on
va parler un petit peu des joueurs
qualifiés maintenant donc vainqueur de
ce tournoi dont christian bauer déjà
français s'il croit la grosse grosse
surprise de ce tournoi on va revenir
juste après j'ai continué à citer les
les qualifiés donc tony miles niche bord
du sport qu'est donc volant d un jeune
hollandais en pleine progression
johnatan speedman homogène et renderman
alors que dead rising des merdes à main
sont moins connus dans le monde des
échecs alors peut-être que tu peux juste
en dessous
voyez sont ses joueurs donc ils ont un
peu créé la surprise donc je redis ma
gamme a créé la surprise dans la mesure
où lui ça fait très longtemps qu'on le
voit dans le circuit qu'il a son
classement elo est monté en flèche
sans jamais qu'il remporte deux grands
tournois donc ici c'est une chose une
chose faite puisque quand même lice et
qualifiés donc pour le championnat du
monde
par contre dimitri renderman lui c'est
tout le contraire c'est à dire on l'a
presque jamais vu il vient juste
d'émerger un peu du paquet de du paquet
de candidats et donc qui signe ici une
très très belle performance
ça fait quelques temps qui commençait à
titiller les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
mais là donc il a prouvé que même sur
tout un tournoi en tournoi entier qui
dure quand même dix jours neuf parties
il a réussi à se qualifier
donc voilà donc on revient maintenant
sur la superbe performance de christian
christian bauer christian bauer c'est un
jeune joueur français fait partie d'un
petit peu de la nouvelle génération des
grands maîtres français avec son but en
la cité eloi évidemment on va citer
peut-être laurent frayssinet et on va
citer pierre bacro évidemment tous les
jeunes français dont qui ont entre 15 et
25 ans on va dire constituent la relève
vraiment des échecs français et chaque
français qui sont pleines pleine
progression
puisqu'on n'a jamais eu autant de m le
drame être en france depuis sept
dernières années
peut-être plus un détail et loi qui va
nous parler de christian bauer un joueur
qu'on ne connaît encore pas trop mais
pourtant qui a déjà été champion de
france
oui alors christian bauer pendant très
longtemps on l'a surnommé le grand
maître national alors que donc c'est un
peu ironique puisque normalement les
tous les grands maîtres sont
internationaux bien entendu on l'avait
surnommé comme ça puisque c'est donc ses
performances de grands maîtres et ne les
faisait que pendant les championnats de
france
il a toujours c'est l'un des seuls
tournois qui réussissait
systématiquement très très bien tous les
ans il faisait au championnat de france
une performance bien au-dessus de son
niveau donc ici
c'est ça bon et bien entendu la
meilleure performance de toute sa
carrière puisqu'il remporte à un tournoi
de classe mondiale donc qu'il a dominée
de bout en bout donc christian et jeune
christian ne travaille pas trop les
échecs qui vient de devenir
professionnel il un style un peu
excentrique
donc ils jouent des ouvertures un peu
surprenante pas très connus pas
forcément très bonne mais qui disons
qu'ils ont le mérite de surprendre et de
dérouter un peu tous ses adversaires
donc je ne sais pas trop ce qu'on peut
dire de plus sur sur ce jeune joueur
donc ici on va commenter une de ces
bonne partie de ses victoires contre des
films of qui est un grand maître italien
on va donc passer à cette partie donc ce
qu'on peut noter quand même c'est que
christian bauer grâce à cette excellente
récompense rentrer un petit peu dans
l'histoire des échecs ou moins de
français puisque les joueurs d'échecs
que français qui ont participé au cycle
finale finalement d'un championnat du
monde se comptent sur les doigts des
deux mains je pense à peu près sur les
doigts d'une main puisque y accueillir
que joël lautier donc et christian bauer
ceux de mémoire je crois qu'ils
participent éliminé au premier tour
non non par un bulgare non non non non
ont eux aussi oui peut-être que je suis
se désole parigot rigueur gâtés vc je me
rappelle donc etienne bacrot avait
bénéficié d'une wild card c'est à dire
qu'il ne s'était pas qualifié en passant
par le tournoi zonal mais il avait été
qualifié directement par la fédération
internationale des échecs en tant que
vraiment jeune prodige puisqu'il avait
été le plus jeune grand maître de tous
les temps en tant qu'invité
historiquement on peut parler on peut
remonter un peu dans le temps on a
maintenant des joueurs français de renan
et notamment enfin le champion du monde
à liquide dans les années 30 on transite
de russie évidemment à l'alexandra
liquide mais c'est vrai que les joueurs
français qui participent au championnat
du monde d'échecs se comptait avant
vraiment sur le sur le doigt on va dire
et grâce à noter dans ce résultat de
christian bauer ça rajoute une pierre de
plus cet édifice on a de plus en plus de
joueurs français qui arrive à ce stade
de la compétition on souhaite évidemment
grande chance à christian bauer et votre
l'ambassadeur de la france
ces championnats du monde qui auront
lieu à las vegas on y reviendra
en deuxième partie alors pour
concrétiser un petit peu disons le
parcours de christian bauer dans ce
tournoi parcours exceptionnel qui fait
une performance qui le place sur ce
tournoi au niveau des tout meilleurs
joueurs du monde on va commenter une de
ces parties
de quel bois m'a recommandé notamment
recommandé pour l'émission il s'agit
d'une partie où christian chesnot preuve
d'une grande grande maîtrise stratégique
notamment consistant à un petit peu à
casser la structure adverse donc on va
rentrer un peu plus dans la technique on
va essayer de le commenter cette partie
est de vous faire vivre un petit peu les
moments importants de cette partie on
essaie donc de faire vivre le parcours
de christian bauer donc efimov grand
maître international 2530 points elo oui
donc c'est un acquis la nationalité
italienne mais bon il l'a c'est un
émigrant bien sûr puisqu'il viendra
aussi comme la plupart des grands
maîtres européens donc donc efimov
oui je les ai battus il ya pas longtemps
enfin ça c'est petite parenthèse mais il
joue il joue très très bien vu que de
1530 c'est un classement qui le placent
dans le top 150 on peut dire alors si
vous voulez suivre cette partie avec
nous donc nous allons démarrer un petit
peu l'analyse cette partie nous allons
faire défiler les coûts je vous
conseille évidemment pas de la de la
page vous avez des indications pour
télécharger donc un logiciel qui vous
permettra de télécharger le fichier de
la partie et vous pourrez suivre les
coûts sur ce logiciel et vous pourrez
suivre donc l'évolution de la partie et
j'espère grâce à nos commentaires qu'on
présente un petit peu mieux la grande
maîtrise de christian bauer qui doit
donc jouer avec les noirs contre un
grand maître international de très fort
niveau à ce tournoi dont qualificatif au
championnat du monde donc une partie
cruciale des films en salles et blanc et
démarre l'ouverture par un des quatre
donc auparavant vous aurez téléchargé ce
logiciel de jeu vous re situer en bas de
la page évidemment vous télécharger ce
logiciel et vous chargez la partie et
vous pouvez suivre la partie sur ce
logiciel est écouté nos commentaires en
même temps donc eloi peut-être tu vas
donc nous commenter la partie donc voilà
un défi mode démarre avec le pion de
l'adoption de la dame bon c'est on a le
choix entre l'option du roi kelkoo
principal disons dans plus de 50% des
partis on ouvre par l'option du roi ici
bon il a joué un des quatre cavaliers f6
cavaliers f3e 6 ou alors ça c'est un
coup typique de christian bauer eu cet
os 6 enfin bon disons c'est un des coups
une des défenses les plus les plus jouer
aux échecs restions affectionne bien ce
système on est au deuxième coup on est
au deuxième coup voilà donc là il va
prix là et prévoit la sortie rapide du
fou est fluide
le foot casse noir pour un rock rapide
donc puisque nos échecs nos l'ouverture
il ya trois objectifs premiers objectifs
sortir ces pièces deuxième objectif
prendre le centre troisième objectif
mettre l'europe à l'abri
cette par le rock donc ici il fait en
trois coups ces trois objectifs
voilà alors nous continuerons de 3,1
coup pas très ambitieux puisqu'ils
ferment la diagonale du fou c'est un
donc son le fond blanc de cases noires
avant de l'avoir sorti donc le fou va
être un peu emmuré par cette promotion
comme on le verra par la suite
donc le fou
le foot blanqui à côté de la dame et qui
actuellement est bloqué par ses propres
pions voilà donc les blancs vont devoir
trouver une solution pour lui donner de
l'air puisque aux échecs on va essayer
évidemment que toutes les pièces
contrôle maximum de case 1
donc pour l'instant c'est un peu petite
concession que font les blancs mais
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui est
quand même si une ouverture qui connut
ses plages des idées clash était caché
derrière ceci voilà on nous déroule un
petit peu la partie donc b6 là christian
va mettre son fou ce qu'on appelle en
fouillant piétons
c'est à dire en baisse est donc ils
avancent leurs pions pour sortir le fou
sur la case libéré voilà donc nous
continuons fou des trois relais blanc
développe leur pièce coup normal de
développement les noirs pareil sortent
leur fou voilà entre les deux grandes
diagonales
oh là là donc efimov vient de faire le
con appelle le petit europe
oui donc ils voient ils viennent de
mettre son roi à l'abri voilà tout à
fait donc christian bauer continue
également son développement
donc bon pour l'instant pas grand chose
à dire puisque c'est la phase de
l'ouverture qui n'est quand même pas la
phase la plus passionnante dans une
partie d'échecs
en général les joueurs se contentent de
répéter des coûts qu'ils connaissent
déjà des plans qu'ils ont établi à la
maison ou ce genre de choses mais c'est
vraiment pas la tuer ya tout là tout le
piment du jeu et s'est passé vraiment
pas là qu'on prend le plus de plaisir à
jouer une partie d'échecs donc un gros
pinceau parler peut-être de lutte
psychologique d'un l'ouverture puisque
en général on essaie d'amener
l'adversaire sur des ouvertures ou des
positions qu'ils aiment pas trop
oui et éventuellement en plus d'amener
la partie sur une position qu'on a envie
de jouer
oui mais bon ça c'est donc on va pas non
plus on va pas parler de tous les échecs
en une heure une partie
on va passer l'ouverture voilà donc
christian prend le centre ce qui est
donc l'un des premiers prix enfin un des
principes de l'ouverture b3 donc là
voilà le fameux fou qui étaient enfermés
en c1 ici va sortir donc puisqu'il peut
plus sortir par là il va sortir par là
donc le fou s'apprête à aller en b2 qui
sera gauche ressentir à droite voilà
donc christian mais sao à l'abri le fou
vient en b2 on pourrait citer aucun
échange de piolenc en échange de pièces
ouais ça reste la position est
pratiquement symétriques on peut
remarquer pour l'instant donc là on en
est au 8ème couffo b2 la position est
totalement symétrique
sauf que les blancs ont déjà sorti leurs
cavaliers dame
donc vous pouvez remarquer que le
cavalier dame est sortie de
un as des deux ce qui n'est pas
forcément une bonne chose puisque
christian va maintenant montrer que
c'est une précision en sortant lui son
cavalier sur une autre case donc on
regarde il joue ses 5
donc ils attaquent le 5 il commence à
attaquer le centre donc les films of
joue un coup d' attaque cavaliers sur
lequel centrale qui centralise
centralise une pièce ils amis ou simples
puisque pied son simple contre le les
cases plus dangereuse pour l'adversaire
voilà pour schématiser on peut dire que
la pièce quand elle vient sur une case
centrale a une énergie potentielle
supérieure donc pour ce qu'on fait de la
physique
voilà donc le guépard premier conseil et
loire ou l'ain mais voilà elles prennent
de la force et donc là christian va
démontrer enfin pas encore disons il va
tenter de mettre son cavalier sur les
dix ans sur un chemin différent de celui
employé le grand maître efimov il m
cavaliers ans et 6 donc à mon avis c'est
une meilleur casque d2 donc nous allons
voir la suite de la partie alors ici les
blancs sont devant un problème ils ne
savent pas ils ne savent plus en fait
comment améliorer leur position
maintenant qu'ils ont sorti toutes les
pièces ils savent plus trop quoi faire
alors ici va montrer un peu qu'elle ait
vraiment qu'elle était vraiment son idée
en fait par ce troisième coup un peu un
peu restreint un peu petit le de fermer
la diagonale du fou le pion aux trois
deals troisième coup ici efimova montré
qu'il avait vu quand même plus loin il
avait bien anticipé et joue f4 donc là
c'est ce qu'on appelle la tacc de
pillsbury qui date du xviiie siècle
donc c'est un système quand même bien
connu les blancs projet de passer la
tour ici sur la case f3 sur la kf3
possible d'avancer la turquie près du
roi donc de trois cases un avant et un
tuellement de la deuxième place et de la
déplacer soit en g3 soit en h3 et pour
viser pour viser donc le roi de
christian voilà donc une menace
en quelques coups qui peut être
désagréable pour les noirs tout à fait
alors d'autant plus que toutes les
pièces blanches ont été placés dans ce
sens là donc si vous avez bien la
position sur votre écran après 10 f 4
ici les blancs on leur fout le four b2
qui est prêt à taper sur le roi fou de
quatre mois
le fauteuil noir vise indirectement il
ya encore des pièces qui gêne mais
peuvent très vite disparaître qui vise
donc la case g7 près du roi
le foot est roi qui lui vise la case h7
donc on a parlé des cases noires
maintenant les cases blanches aussi sont
contrôlés et effectivement la case
achète près du roi casse faible oui tout
à fait
donc tout ça a aidé par la tour puis par
la dame d un qui est prête à arriver à
l'action soit par f3 soit g4 soit h5 une
fois que le cavaliere 6 aura été déviée
donc toutes les pièces blanches sont
vraiment prêtes à entrer dans l'attaqué
donc ça peut être très dangereux pour
christian voilà donc la tacc pillsbury
qui donc qui a déjà maté plus d'une fois
alors la noce et ça va être surprenant
de voir avec quel sang froid
christian là résisté donc il joue tour
s'est vite un coup qui n'a l'air de rien
donc un coût qui contrôle une colonne
qui à tout moment que s'ouvrir c'est à
dire que les noirs peuvent échanger par
exemple au centre
oui et la tour tout de suite aurait
devant elle une grande colonne pour une
action qui peut être qui peut s'avérer
décisive plus tard dans la partie
oui donc il passe une tension une
position qui plus active a priori que sa
case de départ
mais pour l'instant ils ne s'occupent
absolument pas de la défense de son roi
les blancs prennent une petite
précaution joue le pion de à 2 ans à 3
pour empêcher le cavalier noir en c6 de
surgir en b 4 où il viendrait prendre le
fou détroit le fou détroit qui est la
meilleure pièce d'attac blanche puisque
donc vous voyez y contrôler toutes les
cases est donc surtout la case h7 qui
est donc une la casse clés du roi et
demi alors donc à trois un coup calme
christian à 6 toujours calme donc là
efimov va se lancer à l'attaqué
life in a fait le plein de combien voilà
donc aux deuxièmes couteaux f3 et ça y
est la menace maintenant blanche et de
placer sept tours angers troyes ou h3
donc à la droite de façon avisée le roi
adverse avec des menaces de sacrifices
éventuelles contre le roi et
6 2 le matin le plus rapidement possible
puisqu'on rappelle évidemment le cool le
but aux échecs c'est de mettre le roi
adverse
échec et mat c'est à dire de ne puisse
plus partir et qu'il soit lui même en
échec
tout à fait là les blancs vise
absolument à ce résultat le plus vite
possible en fait oui donc la g6 un coup
de défense
une réaction anticipée christian donc
prévoit ce qui risque d'arriver et donc
ferme la diagonale du fou détroit que
l'on a mentionné comme étant la pièce
blanche la plus active
donc on voit maintenant que le foot a
vraiment sur un mur en béton
c'est à dire le pion g6 vous avez la
position après donc 12 g6 des noirs
l'option g6 s'est défendue par le pion à
vii par le pion à vii et donc il est
totalement inconcevable pour les blancs
d'oeufs pour l'un disons pour l'instant
de prendre de prendre angers 6 mais par
contre on peut envisager ce qu'on
appelle sacre aux échecs des sacrifices
c'est à dire pourquoi pas à pour les
blancs de mètres la tour en g3 répit de
sacrifier évidemment est la pièce un g6
par exemple cavaliers et si de noir
reprennent leur sacrifier une pièce par
exemple fou pour pouvoir préfère tout
reprend échec au roi et ça pourrait
éventuellement être dangereux oui
évidemment
faut pas se tromper parce que sinon on a
plus de matériel tout à fait c'est
vraiment à double tranchant les
sacrifier son échec c'est un des grands
une des grandes un décompte n est en
tout cas les noirs doivent faire
attention à toutes ces possibilités
essayer de développer eux-mêmes leurs
initiatives leur attaque tout en faisant
attention à ne pas oublier que le roi et
est sous le feu des pc et wii donc ici
les blancs quand même s'aperçoivent que
ça va être dur de passer après soucoupe
défense g7 g6 donc les blancs jouent
dans me2 alors donc ce coup donc vous
voyez treize dames eu deux attaques le
pion à 6 la dame 2 et le foot est roi
visent le pion à 6,5 là les blancs
menace tout simplement fou prend pion à
6 les noirs reprendre et du fou et d'un
profond qui gagne un pion voilà donc
peut-être les noirs ont intérêt
évidemment à essayer de murray cette
menace bien entendu à ce niveau là on
peut dire qu'un pion de plus sans
compensation
là vraiment réel est clair ça signifie
vraiment la perte de la partie et
wallace idées noires d'une structure ils
n'ont pas vraiment d'attac compenser ce
pion qui risque de perdre la partie
ouais plus tard après beaucoup
d'échangés du blanc pourrait faire une
dame par exemple avaient leurs pions de
plus et puis arrivé à mater le roide
donc évidemment faut pas donner des
pions comme ça sans avoir bien juger
donc tout simplement des cinq descentes
la bonne défense
alors ce coup crée une menace
d'enfermement donc si vous voyez la
position les noirs menace ces cinq c4 et
le fou des trois toujours se fout des
3rv vraiment qui pose des problèmes
l'élan elle serait enfermée donc par le
pion g6 d'un côté et l'option c4 de
l'autre
qui donc très rapidement lancer
effectivement la menace des noirs les
noirs pousserait le client de ces cinq
ans et quatre attaquants me fout les
blancs pour reprendre le pion des trois
premiers pions mais les noirs prendrait
avec le plan b 5 et le fou n'a plus de
gaz il est obligé par hussards sac à dos
aux sacrifiés contre le pian et les
noirs gagne un fond contre deux pions
d'accord donc là on va passer les coûts
suivants sont forcées qui ont français 5
par an la menace et ouvrant au passage
la diagonale du fou b2 wallonie tenant
le fou dont deux cases noirs des blancs
maintenant que les blancs viennent donc
des charges et en c5 se réveille et tout
de suite la diagonale vers le roi noir
menace d'être très très très dangereuse
et de créer des menaces près du roi noir
donc il faudra que l'on fasse attention
faux procès 5 la reprise normale et la
tourache 3 alors que trois années donc
loin quand on l'attaqué mais on peut
noter quand même que christian avec
souffrance et 5 lui aussi comme un sacré
des menaces sur laurent blanc puisse
quand ils voient que le pion que le fou
attaque ne peut plus bouger parce que si
il bougeait le fou c'est 5 mettra des
chèques laurent blanc oui
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le clouage
le clouage donc cette ce pion aux trois
éclopés ne peut pas bouger pour
l'instant [ __ ] tenus en respect par le
fou c'est 5
oui alors donc on peut revenir un petit
peu sur les changes des caps français 5
donc c'est un peu à double tranchant
également une fois de plus puisque donc
d'un côté ça ou la diagonale du fou
blanc en b2 mais de l'autre côté on perd
ce qu'on appelle un pion central alors
les pions centrale c'est très important
en fait ça détermine un peu tout la
lutte dans une partie d'échecs
le joueur qui a le plus d'options
centraux possède l avantage c'est un peu
les ce qu'on disait dans les principes
d'ouverture prendre le centre alors ici
on échange et un pion de la colonne des
contres un pion de la colonne s'est donc
les noirs ont fait une bonne affaire sur
le plan positionnelle alors maintenant
est ce que la taxe va compenser cet
affaiblissement positionnelle c'est ce
qu'on va voir puisque ça ouvert le four
b2 et la tour est déjà en jeu alors on
peut noter aussi peut-être plus tard que
effectivement les blancs réussi à ouvrir
la limonade de leurs fumoirs met donc du
coup les noirs eux mêmes en diagonale
qui va vers le roi blanc avec le fou en
c5 qui est attaque indirectement l'euro
à enghien et peut-être aussi maintenant
le fou 17 dès que le pinot noir des cinq
pour pourra rejouer en d4 par exemple
tout de suite attaque une case qui
proches durable en aussi donc on a
l'impression que les deux camps attaque
chacun le roi et demi donc ça devient
une position à double tranchant ça
commence à chauffer et l'a donc
christian jouen bons coups cavaliers
prend cavaliers allégeant la tension
centrale éliminant la meilleure pièce
blanche qui était ce cavalier fort en 5
et l'a donc assez surprenant efimov
reprend avec le pion en fait c c'est
encore à double tranchant c'est encore
un coup à double tranchant puisque il
aurait très bien pu reprendre avec le
fou à ce moment là c'est cela qui il
il aurait pas ouvert la colonne en
relais d'arrière peut-être y voir sur le
coup donc juste avant donc les noirs
viennent de prendre en scène vous pouvez
avait trop votre logiciel vous pouvez
revenir en arrière donc nous sommes
maintenus numéro 15 et les noirs
viennent de jouer cavalier prend
cavalier e 5
les blancs deux possibilités pour
reprendre soit il reprendra avec le
fouquet tambédou ils reprennent cinq
soit avec le pion donc c'est un choix à
faire
le problème c'est qu'en général c'est
quand on prend avec des pions c'est
comme pion à une mobilité restreinte
donc une fois qu'il est placé sur une
quasi peu plus trop bouger oui par
contre si on prend avec une pièce on
garde la pap la possibilité au pian de
jouer
autre cas alors donc surtout ce qu'il
faut noter c'est que une fois qu'on a
repris avec le pion donc vous pouvez
jouer le 16e coup f-35 et 16e coup les
blancs prennent le cavalier a eu 5
alors ici ça fait un gros problème de
structure de pions puisqu'on a deux
pions doublé donc c'est à dire qu'ils
sont sur la même colonne ce qu'on
appelle des pions doublé et en plus
d'être doublé ce qui est déjà pas un
avantage ils sont isolés
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de pion à
côté pour les défendre donc ses pions
qui sont à eux 5 et 3 sont
potentiellement des faiblesses pour les
blancs puisqu'ils vont avoir du mal à
les protéger
parce qu'en général on protège
facilement une pièce 28 ans par un autre
pion oui parce que le seul matériel qui
coûte pas trop cher
voilà mais là c'est qu'ils ont là n'ont
pas de possibilité d'être soutenus par
d'autres pions donc ça devient ce qu'on
appelle aux échecs des faiblesses c'est
à dire des cibles possibles pour les
noirs qui eux n'ont pas de faiblesse
vous noterez que tous les pions noirs où
toutes les pièces noires sont toutes
bien protégés oui tout à fait alors
pourquoi est ce que un grand maître du
niveau des films of at il choisi de
reprendre avec l'option f
on est quand même en droit de se poser
la question puisque ça a l'air vraiment
d'une aberration sur le plan
positionnelle alors j'espère est-il en
choisissant cette option
c'est très simple il il a ouvert la
colonne f vers le roi de christian valat
la colonne est donc la casse juste à
gauche du roi blanc
un montant qui évidemment si on mettait
une tour par exemple sur cette case on
voit qu'on a une tour disponible sur la
case à 1
on aurait tout de suite une grande
colonne ouverte qui permettrait de taper
sur proche du roi noir donc l'idée de ce
qui nous est fait prend 1,5 et peut-être
donc effectivement d'ouvrir avec leurs
colonnes et d'avoir une possibilité
supplémentaire d'attaquer le roi noir
voilà recontre puisqu'on en a parlé
le fou blanc du coup le fonds qui
étaient en b2 maintenant à plus d'action
est bloqué par son propre pions oui mais
alors donc ici ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que dans un avenir assez proche
les noirs devraient vraisemblablement
être obligé de pousser leurs pions f7
puisque ce pion
quand même bloc un peu la sortie du roi
il imite vraiment disons la mobilité du
camp noir avec un pion au peps est on a
du mal à passer
d'un côté soit à gauche soit à droite
donc quand le pion est pas là une tour
ans et 7 pourrait venir défendre ici
avec le pion elle peut pas
je pense que si on sera menée
normalement à bouger et à ce moment là
on fera la prise soit normal soient
prises en passant et le fou ressurgira
vous prendrez donc de la france
reprendre et de la force donc on peut
continuer la partie alors maintenant
évidemment christian son cavalier en
fils qui est attaqué par le pion il faut
qu'ils réagissent voilà de suite donc il
le met en å 4 bien entendu pour limiter
la force
voilà encore une fois le centre toujours
les pièces au centre donc voila nous
passons food et 4 un coup solide donc là
si christian donc regardez bien la
position après le 17e coublanc food et 4
il invite un peu les noirs à faire une
faute positionnelle si christian avait
décidé de jouer fou prend fou pour
échanger des pièces le pion aux trois
viendrait reprendre le fou des 4es à ce
moment là les pions qui était doublé se
remettrait dans une position vie celle
de l'église où ils s'aident mutuellement
et donc ça serait vraiment une bonne
opération pour yéfé nof
alors bien entendu le fou noir en
bessette sauverait totalement bloquée
par son pion n'y a plus la possibilité
d'un tellement de julie oui le fousseret
serait emmuré par ses propres armes
attention les noirs surtout ne pas
prendre les quatre points
donc là peut-être maintenant f5 et les
coûts donc c'est ce que tu disais loi
les noirs on sent obligé de se donner de
l'air un petit peu pour éviter que le
roi soit lui-même un ferme et avec qui
sait se donner un peu d'air
donc on attend maintenant qu'après la
prise en passant le fou peut être
échangée donc n'est plus un argument
d'attac déterminant au cas où
donc ne prennent pas wallraff dit de
mettre leurs cavalières f3 être un peu
passé quelques coups
dams est donc là c'est des coups
vraiment c'est une séquence en fait qui
n'a que peu d'intérêt
on remarque quand même que christian
crée une menace sur le pion à 3 wii
comprend un peu comme l'avait fait fi
mof donc la position si mes narines le
pian et protégé par à tour donc s'il
vous prend à 3 pour prendre à trois
dames 23 c'est pas possible de reprendre
le fou donc les noirs menace de gagner
voilà donc à 4 si on prend 1,4 si on
prend à 4 donc surtout reprend à 4 il y
avait un problème
regardez la position après 19 b prompt à
4 19e coup noire des points 4 et
envisager maintenant tout reprend à 4 il
suivrait fou prend food et 4
ah oui j'en prends fou des cadres etc
avaient laissé trois fourchette
fourchette donc leur quotidien on
éliminerait le défenseur de la casse ces
trois voies l'argent fou prend fou
puisque le fou contrôle a cassé trois
qui ont prendre cavaliers prendre les
blancs et ensuite cavalier en c3 attaque
la dame et la tour et la tour donc la
dame sont obligés de jouer et ensuite on
fait cavalier prendront donc la tour ne
peut pas prendre un cas voilà donc b
prend un tiers des pièges de notre ami
christian est alors donc ici la position
mérite une photo au niveau positionnelle
niveau structure de pions
après 20 des prix à 4 si vous regardez
les pions blancs easy à
le pion à 4 qui est tout seul le pion c2
qui est tout seul le pion aux trois qui
est tout seul le pion e5 qui est tout
seul alors ça fait quatre faiblesses
alors que le noir alors que les noirs
ont une belle chaîne de pions tous les
pions se tenant mutuellement il ya que
le pion à 6 qu'isolé mais ça fait une
faiblesse contre 4 donc on peut dire que
stratégiquement christian a déjà gagné
la partie et maintenant on va voir à
quelle technique il arrive à conclure un
suivi scolaire menace fou prend pion à 6
puisque la dame protège puisqu'en
faisant b prend à 4 des noirs en libérer
la puissance du football un nom voilà la
menaça apparaît donc à 5 facile
bien joué de la part de christian donc
fou prend ses cinq tours france et 5 et
cavaliers des quatre donc là par cette
séquence du 20e 22e coup les blancs ont
changé leur bloqueur c'est à dire que le
fou qui bloquaient en d4 a été remplacé
par le cavalier qui bloque maintenant
donc les noirs jouent alors voilà ici
christian commence une manoeuvre superbe
son cavalier henri iv qui est une pièce
centralisée qui donc ne devrait pas
changer de place en principe il va le
replacer puisque c'est en fait la seule
pièce qui est capable d'aller manger le
pion aux 5
alors il faut bien suivre le chemin de
ce cavalier maintenant ça va être assez
amusant cavaliers g5
donc là on assiste à une manoeuvre de
cavaliers
qu'on peut qualifier d'historique
d'ailleurs puisque christian s'est
qualifiée aux championnats du monde et
c'est une grande manoeuvre de cavaliers
ou une de celles qui ont déjà vu jouer
par car pauvre parle donc tu étais à
mettre dans le maniement des cavaliers
et l'attrition va nous faire un ballet
de cavaliers remarquable
je m'applique 1 mais il va faire un bel
est remarquable quand même touché trois
cavaliers f7 voilà le cavalier se
replace pour attaquer le pion donc le
pion aux cinq maintenant un cavalier
donc la manette de ce cavalier
consistait à attaquer ce qu'on me disait
tout à l'heure la faiblesse ceux qui on
sait maintenant qu'on en arrive là on
protège espion voilà donc c'est a priori
plutôt que de se borner à une défense
dure et longue
après cavaliers f3 qui sur le sur quoi
les noirs suivrait par dmc 7 donc la
position après vingt-trois cavaliers f 7
coups des noirs efimov se décide à
échanger en fait le pion eux cinq
centrales contre le pion à 5 dont qui
joue cavalier b3 ne se contentant pas de
défendre mais allant à la contre attaque
donc attaque la tour évidemment une tour
et plus fortes comme cavalier donc ils
n'auront pas intérêt évidemment et ses
sept tours sous la prise du cavalier
dont qui retire leur tour mais du coup
le pion à 5 est perdu voilà tour c'est
cette cavale est prompt à 5
donc le fou est plus fort qu'un cavalier
donc christian retire son fou on notera
qui prend vraiment son temps pour aller
chercher le bureau 5
le q5 ne va pas s'envoler il peut pas
défendu il va pas partir il va pas
s'échapper
christian lepron quand il veut donc
d'abord fois vite et après on va prendre
le pion cavaliers b3 et film offre place
ces pièces qu'elle prend 5 ça y est on a
pris l'option donc maintenant qu'est-ce
qui se passe
la position est critique que comment va
se dérouler cette partie les blancs ont
toujours des faiblesses mais maintenant
donc trois pions isolé à 4 c 2 et 2 3
oui alors que les noirs une superbe
structure de pions unique et surtout
trois pions quasiment qui sont centres
ont quand même eu un seul pour les
blancs donc ils menaces d'avalanches de
pions quand c'est purement bush
ils ont créé des menaces terribles vers
le centre est arrivé peut-être très vite
affaire d'âme
en tout cas c'est une menace fort
potentiel mais qui va très vite se
mettre en marche
oui donc donc question va faire valoir
ce qu'on appelle ce que nîmes dovic
appelait déjà au 19e siècle
la marée de pions quand même donc la
marée de pions ici les pions vont se
mettre en avant vont aller vers l'avant
et vont complètement déchiqueté les
pièces blanches puisque on rappelle donc
quand même qu'un pion vaut un point et
chaque pièce vous soit trois points pour
le fou trois points pour le cavalier 5
points pour la tour donc quand un pion
attaque une pièce la pièce a obligé de
reculer
si on a encore un autre pion pour aller
attaquer une nouvelle fois une nouvelle
pièce la pièce va encore reculer et les
pions vont avancer indéfiniment avec
simplement ce chantage au point puisque
un tiens vaut un point et la pièce vaut
trois points
voilà donc là quelques coups de rafales
de coups qu'on m'a peut-être rallier
rapidement qu'ils seraient donc les
plantes poussent leurs pions passé les
noirs sorte le cavalier qui empêche les
pions de bouger voilà pour f3 donc les
blancs se rendent compte que leur
attaque et bella plus lieu d'être
donc j'essaie de rapatrier un petit peu
leur tour cavaliers des six bien joué on
met le cavalier derrière les pions les
pièces derrière les pions et maintenant
ça va donc les films of sur place tant
bien que mal son attaque un fiasco total
la tour revient aussi vite qu'elle
manoeuvre de tourin qui a consisté à
bouger la tour f 3 ap une femme pour
essayer de rapatrier ces pièces puisque
ça tours angers troyes n'avait plus
d'action valable puisque le roi noir est
suffisamment bien défendu donc ça y est
on envoie les purs et sayeda grosse
menace tout de suite
29e coup noire les noirs jouent eux 5 et
donc on voit vraiment que la lecture on
commence à avancer tour à deux défis
move toujours en quête de plomb
sa position est vraiment un social
oppositionnel un coup nous demandent
quelle est l'idée de ce poulain oui à
mon avis il était déjà désespérée pour
cette édition d'alger 5
le problème aussi aux échecs c'est de
savoir trouver des idées et l'ail
finement séduit une situation où avec
ses faiblesses n'est plus qu'à une
position dans fait d'attentes des idées
de l'adversaire oui c'est un petit peu
ça en fait il sait pas trop quoi faire
en fait oui donc ce qu'on peu ce qu'on
pourrait dire en fait c'est un peu une
notion de jeu statique et jeu dynamique
donc ici les noirs ont gagné la partie
si la partie venait à se poursuivre sur
le long terme c'est à dire ce qui va se
passer en fait les blancs manque de
manque d'arguments positionnelle donc
plus la partie se prolonge plus les
noirs ont des chances de gagner alors
normalement les blancs devraient donner
le tout pour le tout devrait tenter une
attaque surprise une attaque éclair
quelque chose de vraiment d'hi-media de
ponctuel mais ici c'est vraiment pas
possible donc en principe l'issue du
combat ne fait plus vraiment de doute
la partie devrait se prolonger à
l'avantagé donc du jeu positionnelle
c'est à dire christian donc là ce qu'on
va voir maintenant et rafales de coups
aussi puisque donc les blancs en fait ne
font qu'attendre en ce moment donc ce
que les noirs vont faire il hésite et
attractive pour essayé d'activer toutes
leurs pièces
on revient la foux procès capte est
obligatoire puisque le pur 3 allait
tomber s'ils n'ont donc trente deux
français captent et un confort s'est
dépensé 4 surprenant surprenant enfin
surprenant non il fallait faire un choix
donc vous voyez remettez la position
après 32 blanc four en c4 il faut
choisir entre tour c'est cette plante
pousse et 4 ou qui ont des cinq profs ou
ses cadres alors pour garder la marée de
pions on est tenté de prendre avec la
tour
mais christian à vue au-delà il a vu en
fait qu'il valait mieux ou vriendt la
diagonale du fou le fou dans 48 qui
dormait depuis un petit peu le début de
la partie
oui en fait servi avec une action énorme
puisque deux à huit qui va contrôler des
cases tout près du bois blancs oui
notamment la case g2 créant avec la dame
g5 une batterie qui menace tout
simplement si la dame blanche par
exemple était en 6e
une fois que les noirs on prie madame
projet de schéma échec et mat ya des
menaces qui commencent à voir le jour si
le fond blanc libéré de son action ce
qui fait ce que fait donc christian
philibert l'anc l'action de son fou pour
créer des menaces contre laurent blanc
voilà tu en prends dans 24 à takahashi
avait les bêtes qu'à rallier en b3
lecavalier se retire pour des beats
attaque l'ademe d2 dont canada ne peut
pas les n'importe où puisque la menace
voilà tout à fait comme suit de la
signaler tout à l'heure la dame est
obligé de rester à la défense du pion g2
sous peine de maths et l'a donc tour c
voilà le drame se
ou alors la main la menace est énorme
ici peut-être et loire rapidement donc
la menace bien entendu c'est de mettre
une tour sur la deuxième rangée principe
connu encore depuis nîmes the beach le
19e siècle donc les bases des échecs
date le monde un certain bout de temps
une tour sur la deuxième rangée est un
élément déterminant
pratiquement dans chaque position dans
chaque finale vous pouvez mettre une
tour sur la deuxième rangée ou sur la
septième rangée
vous avez en tout les cas gagné la
partie pratiquement dans tous les cas
donc la grosse menace des noix par
exemple si c'est au nord de jouer mais
sinon qu'il vient de jouer comme à 6
paniers poussent leurs pions tours en d2
attaque la dame évidemment la taille ne
peut pas prendre puisque sinon c'est
l'autre tour qui remplace il en a gagné
une dame
la dame est obligé de jouer mais du coup
on à la tour la dame est le fou qui
attaquent en g2 voyou peut dire c'est un
échec et mat rapide tout de suite après
2 en 2 roues peut-être ya échec et mat
qui va survenir donc il faut absolument
pas raisonnable à tours en d2 donc 35 c
3 alors si un jour et de la part des
films fonctionnent pas bien joué et
disons coup élémentaire seul coup la
tour en a2 du coup protège maintenant la
case l'idée de ce coup-ci 3 et
simplement de libérer l'action de la
tour en a deux qui contrôle cette case
des domaines ainsi tout retour en d2
pour les noirs tout reprend pour prendre
dans prend les blancs gagnent tour donc
évidemment voilà on n'est plus possible
alors donc ici c'est un peu ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur le jeu
statique elle jeu dynamique
les noirs ont toujours gagné la partie
sur le plan positionnelle donc ils vont
pas se presser ils vont simplement
améliorer leur dernière pièce qui
peuvent encore améliorer leur fille
roger 7
alors on peut noter aussi appris ce
courant jet set que les blancs ont leurs
pièces qui sont pas très bien
coordonnées puisque les tournois elle se
protège d'une l'autre ce qui n'est pas
le cas des taux blanche
le fou en a 8 est très bien positionné
puisqu'il n'est pas attaquable
il attaque de très loin le roi le pion
g2 les blancs n'ont que des pièces en
défense et surtout ce cas ralliée en c1
n'a pas de gaz il est marié
oui en b3 puisque le pion en c4
l'empêchent en d3 c'est la même chose et
même les tours attaque aussi et en ayant
eu deux la dame blanche contrôle est
fait
voilà donc là les blancs gigote 36h 3
les noirs améliorent leurs pièces
toujours h 5 tours b 2 les bleus savent
pas quoi faire
h4 donc la halle c'est vraiment la phase
la phase finale en fait dix ans c'est la
conclusion les noirs et c'est d'un flux
d'un fermer totalement les blancs donc à
6 maintenant fou aux quatre on améliore
encore le fou donc toutes les pièces
noires sont arrivés sur leur case
vraiment les meilleurs tours e d'alger 3
on pouvait encore améliorer la dame
donc j'ai dit une une erreur alors
maintenant voilà les plaintes qui ont
joué leur tour essayer de faire activer
leurs cavaliers qui jouait pas mais il
s'éloigne assez loin du lieu du dlna et
la superbe coup de voilà alors mettez la
position du 40e coup sûr votre logiciel
après quarante cavaliers à 2 les noirs
jouent et gagnent donc petite
combinaison que vous devriez pouvoir
trouver
je vous laisse je vais compter jusqu'à 5
donc voilà ça fait 5
c'est donc tout à fait évident il voit
quand même mais c'est vrai c'est
intéressant donc fou projet deux faits
projet de alors que se passe-t-il si la
dame vient reprendre le fou elle
laisserait la tour e 1 sans protection
et donc serait donc il y aurait un
châtiment rapide d'un grand tour échec
tout simplement gagnant donc une tour
est un pion contrat full donc ça fait
donc une tour plus un pion ça fait 6 un
fou vos trois ans gagne 3 points et
comme à partir de 1 point et demi ça
suffit pour gagner la partie
ça fait beaucoup de matériel calculer la
taille de la tacc continuerez puisque
les tours noire pourrait ensuite pénétré
dans le camp royal rob mathes rapide sur
le roi non seulement c
comptablement parlant en termes de
points c'est pas bon mais ça me plaît la
table continue de l'attak continue en
plus d'enfants proches des deux déjà les
noirs derniers mois un pion le roi blanc
maintenant est complètement et privé de
tous ses défenseurs alors efimov trouve
encore un coup rude à metz 2 no 41
fwouedd trois échecs d'un projet 3
forcer le pion à je viens prendre alors
là on peut se demander pourquoi les
blancs abandonne en fait donc d'une part
ils ont un point de moins et le deuxième
gros problème est qu'ils sont matt en
quelques coups par la manoeuvre
tour 17 des deux donc échange de tours
en d2 tour age 2 et tourache un match et
il est complètement imparable si une
manoeuvre un peu longue mais qui est
imparable
mes oeuvres voilà donc une manoeuvre
décisive il ya aussi la menace peut être
il ya cette menace mais il ya aussi
peut-être la menace aussi tour des uns
est par exemple si les blancs prenez en
d1 tout reprend tour d un échec et mat
ou et puisque le royaume l'envoyer ne
peut pas monter ni en chef denis angers
denis en h264 f2 le pion aux contrôles
en g2 le fou contrôle et un jeu de
l'oeuf ou contrôle donc le roi blanc
fait actuellement et un muret et la
pénétration des tours et décisive en
quelques coups le grand maître perd la
partie il a calculé ça évidemment il a
tout à fait vue et donc perdre et la
partie préfère ne pas continuer ils
abandonnent et christian goy remarque le
point oui tout à fait donc une belle
prestation du jeune du jeune christian
donc ce qui est assez amusant en fait
c'est de voir que les blancs qui se sont
jetés sur jeter à l'attaqué dès les
premiers coups de la partie finalement
ce sont eux qui en avançant leurs pions
pour attaquer son ont fini par se faire
mater donc si on regarde tournoi de
christian là on a un visuel une de ces
parties
l'ensemble de ses parties aussi été
remarquable n'a pas perdu une seule
partie n'a perdu aucune partie non il a
fait quelques parties nul n'a pas perdu
une seule très très très bon tournoi de
christian bauer de christian bauer qui
qualifié le seul qualifié français aux
championnats du monde et rejoint les
autres qualifiés donc notamment
l'anglais rival l'anglais aussi miles
lisbonne va jamais à van der man à ce
championnat du monde championnat du
monde d'échecs qui aura lieu à las vegas
en juin en juin alors au début ça devait
être en janvier à las vegas ensuite il
ya eu un petit changement de programme
même dessin je crois c'était prévu en
décembre
après il ya eu un changement de
programme suite dé en gros
d intrigue politico financières entre
karpov et le président de la fédération
internationale d'échecs alors peut-être
et loire avant de continuer on va
peut-être parler de l'historique de ce
nouveau championnat du monde puisque
historiquement donc parlant le
championnat du monde avait lieu sous un
principe un petit peu archaïque qui
était de dire le champion du monde en
titre attend son challenger se
challenger doit se qualifier pour la
phase finale la phase finale consistant
des matchs éliminatoires et le vainqueur
de ce cycle à la fin rencontrer le
champion du monde
ça c'est la formule qui existe depuis
plus d'un siècle oui le champion du
monde attend son challenger et depuis
donc l'année dernière car chan illumine
of nouveau président de la fédération
internationale essayer d'instaurer un
nouveau système est le premier
championnat du monde nouvelle formule a
eu lieu l'année dernière à lausanne à
lausanne renens guen et lausanne grande
nouvelle dans l'agro nigon et lausanne
et peut-être tu peux nous décrire un
petit peu cette nouvelle formule et loi
oui donc là du monde d'échecs ont déjà
une petite remarque personnelle c'est
que moi je préférais l'ancien système
donc
j'aimais bien le système de match un peu
de matches qui n'en finissait pas
puisque les matchs durer jusqu'à six
mois
mais bon ça avait permis d'avoir 13
champions du monde seulement en plus de
100 ans
donc c'est quand même un gros avantage
comparé à la boxe avec plus de treize
championnats du monde si vous tracez
champion du monde simultanément en fait
donc moi j'aimais bien l'ancien système
alors maintenant donc le nouveau système
est donc plus axé vers les médias
donc on s'est mis un peu au goût du jour
c'est à dire que c'est à élimination
directe donc c'est bien c'est à dire que
c'est clair au début il ya 100 joueurs
ensuite y en a cinquante après on en
rêve réintègre quelques-uns pour arriver
à 64 et ensuite élimination directe pour
désigner un finaliste dont c'est à dire
la finaliste de finaliste qui jouent la
finale et donc qui détermine le champion
de confinement alors ça ça c'est
l'organisation idéal du championnat du
monde
trouve que l'année dernière encore
malgré ce nouveau système dont qui était
donc condensé sur un an alors que vous
avez sûrement entendu parler des
championnats du monde qui ont eu lieu
pendant karpov et kasparov qui ont duré
plusieurs mois voir si moi je prends
pour le plus long là ce championnat du
monde et qu'on a c'est sur un mois de
l'année dernière encore afin de faire
jouer car pauvre qui était le champion
en titre qui évidemment pour restaurer
sa nouvelle formule il a fallu que le
président de la fide et trouvent des
compromis notamment karpov cette fois
encore attendait son challenger en
finale mais le championnat a été
écourtée ne duraient plus qu'un mois
pour les qualifiés donc le finaliste de
l'année dernière qui était vice
manhattan allende et le match final
s'est joué sur uniquement si parti au
lieu d'être jouée comme avant aux
meilleurs des 24 parties donc c'était
beaucoup plus court beaucoup plus
spectaculaire même si le joueur la fin
était très fatigué c'était c'est
beaucoup plus éprouvant physiquement
donc ça c'est l'idéal c'est évidemment
d'arriver à un système où le champion du
monde qui n'attend plus et c'est ce qui
devait se passer cette année avec une
avancée dans les dates puisque ce
championnat du monde devait avoir lieu
initialement tous les deux ans c'était
ce qui était annoncé et kirchen nominaux
a voulu prendre de court un petit peu
kasparov qui lui ne participe pas ce
championnat et qu'ils étaient en train
d'essayer des stores et des matchs
parallèle avez vous un petit peu
accéléré le système pour le faire dès
cette année mais cette fois c'est karpov
qu'ils n'étaient pas contents puisqu'ils
s'attendaient à être champion du monde
pour deux ans au départ d'où les
tractations qui ont eu peut-être alors
eloi puis on connais tu connais un peu
plus que ce qui a pu se passer
alors je sais pas je ne sais pas très
bien disons que ça ne touche pas sa
touche pas mon quotidien ce genre de ce
genre d'histoire donc je sais que ça
devait être au début en janvier ou en
décembre à las vegas ensuite ça a été
reportée en mai à et l'istat mais bon
elista comme c'est pas forcément très
bien vu que ce soit dans le même pays
que le président alors il dit cela c'est
donc la carte elle de la kalmoukie calme
qui noted province russe pas vraiment
une province et province autonome en
fait un pays un peu particulier enfin
peu importe donc finalement on a décidé
quand de le faire à las vegas et c'est
reporter je pense en juillet
jean genet 1ère date annoncée
officiellement parle de ce championnat
du monde qui aura lieu à partir je crois
du 19 juin jusqu'au 20 juillet
approximativement donc à las vegas
toujours ce qui est bien pour les échecs
je pense parce que las vegas quand même
ville médiatiquement parlant
intéressante et donc ce championnat du
monde devrait avoir lieu avec avec
airport mais sans kasparov qui refuse
toujours de réintégrer ce nouveau
système donc de championnat du monde lui
il estime qu'il faut garder l'ancien
système et pour cela il veut plus
participer à ces championnats du monde
de champion du monde en titre c'est
anatoli karpov et kasparov lui et en le
titre de meilleur joueur du monde et de
champion du monde de sa fédération de
champion du monde pca
c'est la fédération qui l'a créé
parallèle et mais c'est quand même le
meilleur joueur du monde est en tout cas
estimé comme tel par tous les
commentateurs
étant donné qu'ils comptent continuer à
garder le nez le classement numéro un
au classement de la fédération
internationale donc mais ce championnat
du monde donc devra avoir lieu donc en
juin juillet à las vegas christian bauer
donc s'est qualifié qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire de plus peut-être c'est que eloi on
a un petit problème par rapport ce
championnat du monde puisque étant
annuel le premier a eu en décembre le
deuxième en juin quand on aura eu le
troisième oui enfin le deuxième n'a pas
encore eu lieu donc on se posera la
question plus tard
alors je voudrais pas revenir sur ce que
tu as dit l'actualité mondiale en ce
moment enfin les meilleurs joueurs du
monde
le meilleur joueur du monde n'est pas
forcément kasparov actuellement et ça
tout le monde est en train de le
comprendre un petit peu wisches
manhattan annonce donc un classement qui
approche celui de gary kasparov à
quelques points près et donc en fait
garry kasparov ne maintient son
classement que grâce à une aberration du
système qui fait que si un joueur ne
joue pas il conserve le même placement
alors anand engrange gains après gains
dans tous les tournois
kasparov ne joue pas et conserve son
classement donc on peut vraiment se
demander qui est le meilleur joueur du
monde actuellement alors le classement
peut être on va parler juste un petit
mot c'est le classement elo représente
la force de chaque joueur donc c'est un
nombre de points
à titre indicatif kasparov un classement
approximative je crois de 2815 points
elo et viswanathan anand justement grâce
à au tournoi fantastique qui l'a fait
cette année il en a gagné
il n'y a quasiment plus gagné trois de
suite il a gagné trois de suite contre
les tout meilleurs joueurs du monde sur
les cinq meilleurs du monde et elle a
peut-être kasparov et karpov qu'ils ne
font pas tous les tournois mais devant
tous les autres joueurs il a terminé
premier remportant haut la main
à chaque fois c'est ses prestations et
visons la nana approche des 2800 points
elo et je crois même peut-être son
prochain classement dépassera 2800
points elo donc il est tout près de
kasparov lui en jouant tous les tournois
passeport en ayant joué son dernier
tournoi qu'il ya au moins six mois je
crois même si depuis il a fait des
matches mais plutôt des exhibitions que
des matchs officiels tout à fait bien je
pense qu'on peut reprocher nez sur la
troisième partie de cette émission donc
l'actualité française
donc on va parler des deux tournois des
deux tournois qui ont cours en ce moment
le tournoi de grands maîtres de belfort
et ont un grand maître de clichy donc
toi un drogué de clichés on en a un peu
parlé en début d'émission
donc c'est un tournoi de catégorie 7
alors catégorie 7 c'est ça veut dire
2420 entre 2420 à 2425 de moyenne et
l'eau c'est donc c'est pas un très forte
en droit mais ça réunit quand même un
grand m plusieurs dents m et donc les
candidats à la norme sont assez nombreux
donc une norme peut-être eloi on va en
parler ce qui intéresse évidemment les
joueurs qui n'ont pas le titre soit de
mettre 2 g l dans ces tournois c'est
d'obtenir une norme une norme c'est donc
une performance et on dit normes de
mettre aux normes deux grands maîtres
c'est donc un résultat qu'il faut
obtenir en fonction du niveau du tournoi
et il faut en général donc trois normes
ses lecteurs et sur trois performances
sur trois mois ou deux
à condition qu un des tournois dépasse
je crois 15e rang
je ne sais plus partie mais en gros donc
trois normes pour obtenir le titre qui
est décerné à vie par la fédération
internationale eloi toi tu as obtenu le
titre de grand maître international et
cela d'ailleurs très récemment
oui tout à fait c'est aide au dernier
congrès de la fédération internationale
à l'ista donc le titre n'a été donc
attribué suite donc 3 nombre de grands
maîtres comme tu fais pas ce tournoi
pour la norme évidemment tu fais surtout
main pour essayer de gagner les places
intéressantes au niveau professionnel
voilà c'est ça c'est à dire que une fois
qu'on est grand maître quand même via le
classement elo qui continue soit
augmentée soit abaissée
donc là je fais ce tournoi pour gagner
des points elo et accessoirement pour
permettre aux autres joueurs de réaliser
une norme de promettre 92 m alors grosse
surprise dans ce tournoi c'est le joueur
le moins bien classé qui est en tête
donc c'est l'allemand qui s'appelle
david gosse il est en train de miner le
tournoi il a cinq et demi sur 7
donc il vient de réaliser une norme de m
deux rondes avant la fin du tournoi
il n'est pas encore m donc à 2340 des
lots et donc il peut aussi également
réalisé normes de grand maître s'il fait
un point et demi sur les deux dernières
parties donc affaire à suivre pour ce
tournoi qui en fait un petit thomas
legrand m mais c'est assez exceptionnel
en france vu que tu en a à peu près
trois ou quatre par an et 3 ou 4 oui pas
évident des tournois donc ce qu'on
appelle t-on dans de grands maîtres
c'est donc en attendant qu'on appelle
fermé c'est à dire que tous les joueurs
se rencontrent les uns les autres
donc là je crois qu'il ya combien de
joueurs sont ce tournoi 8 décide
10/10/10 donc ça fait neuf parties
chaque joueur rencontrant les neuf
autres donc il faut que pour quand on
noie et de keats appelle-t-on un grand
maître gênant c'est un endroit fermé on
n'est pas confiant étonnant open où là
on va avoir 200 à 300 voire 1000 joueurs
ce qui arrive tous les ans par exemple
tournoi d'aubervilliers qui sont des
parties rapides on peut être champion de
paris qui est pas loin de ce score
oliphant 800 joueurs régulièrement 1 800
joueurs donc mais là tout le monde
évidemment on peut pas rencontrer tout
le monde mais on fait quand même neuf
parties mais là c'est donc un tournoi
fermé où c'est uniquement par invitation
c'est ce genre de tournoi donc ça
c'était donc le tournoi de clichy
évidemment il ya très peu de tournois
deux grand maître en france est très
important pour niveau général des
joueurs et il ya un autre tournoi qui
probablement plus fort je crois beaucoup
plus fort qui est beaucoup plus fort et
qui se déroule dans la ville de belfort
à l'initiative d'un grand monsieur d
échec puisqu'il a en tout cas organiser
énormément de choses et notamment la
coupe du monde d'échecs tu crois en 1988
il a fait des tournois de ce niveau là
il fait beaucoup pour les échecs des
petits problèmes avec la fédération mais
bon ça on va pas entrer dans les
considérations politiques mais ce
personnage c'est jean paul touzet jean
paul touvier organise ce tournoi dont
qui s'appelle le master's comtois parce
que c'est en franche comté la ville de
belfort est soutenue par les instances
administratives
de la région ce tournoi est exceptionnel
parce qu'on voit la participation du
plus jeunes grands maîtres du monde
actuellement et qui s'appelle rustam
ponoma mono mario fortin alors tu vas
nous parler un petit peu des lois de ce
jeune russe qui n'a pas eu la couverture
médiatique qu'a eue etienne bacrot qui
lui aussi avait obtenu ce titre de plus
jeune grand maître quelques mois avant
oui écrire au stade néma pour nos mario
a détrôné on peut dire etienne bacrot au
niveau mondial au niveau du record du
plus jeune grand maître de l'histoire et
raconte nous un petit peu l'histoire de
ce jeune russe finalement on connaît
très peu de choses
alors donc la russie c'est un énorme
réservoir à joueurs c'est à dire des
champions il en forme depuis des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années
ils sont très très nombreux c'est pour
ça qu'on n'a pas souvent l'occasion de
les connaître puisque y en a un nombre n
ont déterminé complètement indéterminée
donc le jeune ponomariov en fait a
réussi à sortir sa tête du paquet en
fait et donc en gagnant le tournoi zonal
de ça donc de sa zone en russie je ne
sais pas quels ont été les gagnants donc
ce tournoi très facilement il a remporté
il a dominé le tournoi ça fait très
longtemps qu'on le voit il a gagné le
championnat d'europe des moins de 18 ans
quand il avait 13 ans c'est absolument
c'est inimaginable
c'est une performance historique encore
là il va passer au dessus des 2600
points elo au prochain classement tout à
fait exceptionnelle ni kasparov et
karpov ont réussi à avoir un tel
placement à cet âge là donc qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire de plus il se lève à 7h
du matin il fait un jogging à 8h30 il a
commencé à travailler et c'est journée
dure douze heures il fait 12 heures de
travail tous les jours avec des
entraîneurs soviétique comme michail
golubev ou marc vaurette ski qui sont
vraiment des des entraîneurs en fait de
renom et d'exception
donc tous à tous et tout son staff en
fait ce staff plus tôt il l'a eu après
après coup dix ans après après avoir
commencé à rentrer dans le quotidien
donc vraiment un joueur exceptionnel il
en est
deuxième du tournoi actuellement à
belfort après quatre rondes il a trois
points sur quatre est tout à fait tout à
fait bien dans un tournoi où la moyenne
est l'eau et de deux mille cinq cent
soixante dix à peu près vraiment
exceptionnel donc et je crois qu'il a
très bien démarré ce tournoi puisque
actuellement je crois qu'on a des
informations puisque gourévitch mène le
tournoi avec 3 5 points sur quatre mais
pour nous marions suit avec trois points
sur quatre trois points sur quatre on
peut noter également la performance du
plus fort m français arnaud hauchard
alors c'est pas le confort joueurs
français c'est le plus fort maître
puisqu'il n'est pas encore grand maître
mais il a largement le niveau il va
avoir deux mille cinq cent quarante
points elo prochain classement et donc
il a deux points et demi sur quatre il
donc en course pour la norme de grands
maîtres qui dans ce tournoi est à cinq
points sur neuf
voilà donc bonne chance arnaud j'espère
qu'il va qui va bien finir ce tour na li
même parti or je crois qu'on peut noter
quelque chose encore une fois les échecs
se joue sur l'échiquier mais aussi en
dehors de l'échiquier on peut noter
quelque chose amusante puisque etienne
bacrot ont été invités à ce tournoi
donc le jeune russe ponomariov est en
train de faire de très bons résultats
étienne marcoux était invité à ce
tournoi par jean paul touzet et je crois
qu'il a refusé finalement devenir alors
quelle est la raison pourquoi at il
refusé de venir prêter très loin tu vas
tu as une idée peut-être bas c'est pour
des raisons plus ou moins financière il
faut dire que donc etienne bacrot
à une carrière à gérer donc bon il a des
sponsors qui lui permettent pas
forcément de jouer les tournois qu'il a
envie il est tenu par des contraintes
ils ont je ne sais pas trop de quel
ordre
mais toujours est il qu'une rencontre
avec ponomariov l'aurait certainement
contrarier puisque c'est vrai que c'est
quand même difficile d'expliquer qu'on
est le meilleur joueur de sa génération
si on perd en doute une rencontre
directe avec le principal concurrent
maintenant bon je trouve ça dommage
qu'il n'ait pas joué puisque ça c'est
vraiment un tournoi d'une qualité
exceptionnelle vont en france c'est plus
forte en a qui a été organisée en france
dans les 10 dernières années depuis la
coupe du monde de belfort justement donc
c'est vraiment dommage qu etienne n'est
pas participé bon c'est ponomariov qui
joue maintenant donc très belle
performance de ponomariov moi je suis un
peu déçu personnellement qu etienne
n'est pas joué tant pis ça sera pour
plus tard toute façon ces deux joueurs
ces deux jeunes sont comme le futur le
futur échiquier 1 mondial donc bon ils
seront amenés à se rencontrer par la
suite maintenant dommage qu'ils se
dépêchent pas tout de suite
voyez peut-être sept 7 confrontations
at-elle que au championnat du monde 2010
en tout cas on verra le temps nous le
dira je ne sais pas par contre ce qui
peut être intéressant et moi je ne sais
pas si tu connais la prochaine actualité
détienne bacrot est-ce qu'il va jouer
des tournois importants dans le monde ce
qui les invitait ce que tu connais un
petit peu son prochaine sa prochaine
actualité
non en fait je sais que il a changé
d'entraîneur il s'entraîne plus avec
iossif dorfman il s'entraîne maintenant
exo rabat my par yachvili qui habite en
géorgie donc ça fait un peu plus loin
que d'aller à cannes
mais bon donc etienne se tiennent fait
des stages là bas qui dure deux semaines
trois semaines donc s'entraîne là bas
maintenant son planning de tournois je
n'ai absolument aucune idée de quel
engagement il apprit à quel moment
d'accord donc voilà pour l'actualité
française et on va terminer l'émission
sur sur 7 sur ce petit tour d'horizon
donc un petit résumé donc de cette
actualité française le tournoi de clichy
de grands maîtres qui est en train de se
terminer dans la dernière ronde de
dimanche auquel participe le grand
maître et loire linge qui avec vous ce
soir qui sera avec nous pour les
prochaines émissions le tournoi de
belfort plus fortement de l'année en
france on vous fermez avec la présence
du plus jeunes grands maîtres du monde
on stagne ponomariov et l'absence d'
etienne bacrot malheureusement la
prochaine fois nous essaierons de faire
le tour aussi encore une fois de
l'actualité mondiale on fera donc un
bilan de ces deux tournois qui d'ici là
évidemment seront terminés et nous
serrons d'avoir des nouvelles du
championnat du monde évidemment des
prochaines péripéties j'espère que le
calendrier sera définitivement fixé ce
qui semble quand même être le cas et
ainsi que les plus grands aura du monde
notamment il ya une très très forte au
nom qui nous attend puisque fin janvier
visait à tana d'un numéro 2 mondial sera
dans le même tournoi que garry kasparov
qui a décidé de relever le gant
il a envie de démontrer qu'il est encore
numéro un donc fin janvier un très très
fortement à mondiale a commenté
d'ici là évidemment nous aurons des
émissions puisque nous reprenons début
janvier
nous remercions d'avoir suivi cette
émission avec nous j'espère que ça vous
a plu j'espère que vous avez apprécié
les commentaires de la partie efimov
bauer donc du dernier tournoi
qualificatif aux championnats du monde
vous pouvez nous envoyer vos
commentaires vous avez donc les adresses
email
2 de la production de cette émission
pouvez nous envoyer vos commentaires vos
souhaits si vous voulez quand il ya
certaines tournoi vous voulez quand vous
voulez qu'on parle s'il ya d'autres
joueurs sur lesquels vous voulez en
savoir plus n'hésitez pas à nous
contacter nous nous tiendrons compte de
vos remarques
voilà nous irons merci au revoir et donc
à la prochaine émission
merci voilà